bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors des pays en
guerre qui disputent ensemble ça peut
ressembler à quoi se sont de
négociations indirectes
c'est un procès si ça a été relancée
depuis 2010 2012
il n'a pas abouti maintenant il y avait
une percée il avait un accord cadre pour
négocier c'est tout car enfin il y a
deux volets les volets de frontière
maritime qui cache apparemment sa
frontière maritime commune des gisements
de gaz surtout et aussi les frontières
terrestres qu'ils n'ont pas été
définitivement délimiter suite à un
retrait israélien aux l'an 2000 donc il
ya de lucien internationale il ya des
accords l'accord d'armistice de 1949 à
pour lui à l'époque des mandats français
en 1923 puis il y avait d'autres
résolutions internationales 425 et 1701
tous ces dispositifs pourrait servir
avec la médiation américaine et les sous
le contrôle de l'onu et d'avancer dans
ces domaines alors on connaît la
situation du liban crise politique
sociale et économique est ce que ça mais
pas un peu le pays en position de
faiblesse
peut-être cette situation aurait permis
de d'avancé les choses depuis le début
de l'année la visite de porcs bio
l'actuelle mini secrétaire d'état
américain il y avait une certaine
ouverture mais je pense avant tout un
cadre régional plus globale le blocage
entre les rangs et trombe et surtout que
la direction actuelle de l'aileron avant
les élections américaines voulaient
donner un petit cadeau un cadeau
symbolique il ne flaire donc l'iran et
le hezbollah qui domine le liban ont
décidé de faire ce petit pas c'est un
pas plutôt symbolique plus con
profondeur d'ailleurs le liban précise
bien que ces négociations sont
techniques et non pas diplomatique
pourquoi le gouvernement soit il faire à
cette précision car en fin d'école c'est
le consensus à la libanaise
donc cessons de négociations limité pour
délimiter les frontières et c'est tout
et donc il n'y a pas un aspect ni
politique ni diplomatique mais du point
de vue symbolique les symboles aussi
sert beaucoup les fêtes que de liban
sous la houlette des zola accepte de
négocier avec israël
cette question sensible ce quelque chose
comme la trêve entre le hamas et israël
à gaza c'est quelque chose de
reconnaissance tacite de ce raid
alors on sait qu'israël vient de
normaliser ses relations avec certains
pays du golfe le dialogue bien le dire
un s'ouvre avec le guidon à quoi on
assiste en ce moment dans la région
il ya une grande différence
il ya une nouvelle ambiance dans les
golfs et celle en deux gènes de légendes
du golf on constate qu'il ya une
nouvelle hiérarchie des dangers
peut-être les variations dans l'école
que les risques iranien ou leiris
culture qu'il risque de faire musulman
est bien plus élevé que les risques
israélien pour cela et abaissé
sévèrement il y avait cette tentative de
déjouer les équilibres régionaux et
surtout suite à la chute de l'irak en
2003 et la domination de force non
arabes dans les scènes arabe au liban
comme je disais c'est un autre cadre un
cadre de d'un certaine ouverture
iranienne calculs et on va les états
unis et aussi d'un pressions américaines
sur les lbo à vous dire merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et spécialiste du
moyen-orient merci